Hello everybody, I'm Dr. Kevin Cutters. Welcome to another holistic health hour. Hopefully
we're going live on YouTube right now, live on Facebook and live on Instagram. So I hope
everybody can see. If you do have questions, please go ahead and put those questions in.
There are a bunch of questions from last week that we have to go over so we don't get to yours
this week, hopefully we get to them next week. So one question that gave it is, will people
in the vicinity get any benefit? The right question actually was, would people come in to visit my
house, we get benefit from running the right machine? And the most common question that we get
from patients is, is this going to affect my partner and family with me? How's the sleep being
in bed with me? Because we typically write programs where people are using them overnight while they
sleep and of course they're doing that in their bed. So the answer to that is yes and no. So
it depends on what program you're running and it depends also and it has some really clinical
tactically you could measure the frequency up to like 12 feet or so, but really realistically you
have to be closer to that to really get any clinical benefit to using the right machine. So really
about three feet is what I say as you really have to be within that distance. Now it depends
on the bulb that you're using too. We have some patients that are using that they have multiple
patients in the family with Lyme disease, multiple kids with Lyme disease they'll use it. We actually
have them use a little bit different bulb that will go at a greater distance and they set that
in the kitchen table while all the kids are sitting around the kitchen table doing homeschool or
something like that and they can all get some benefit from the rife. The second thing, so the
closeness to the bulb itself makes a big difference. The second thing is what frequencies you're
running. So if let's say you have breast cancer and you're running your breast cancer frequency and
you have your sister come over and visit and she's very close to the bulb city right next to you. Is
she going to get benefit from it? Well not if she doesn't have breast cancer. So the frequencies are
everything with the rife machine remember. So if I have prostate cancer and I'm running colon cancer
frequencies there's a good chance that it's not going to really positively affect my prostate cancer.
So you have to be running the right frequency. So if you don't have the condition that you're running
the frequencies for well then it's really not going to have any positive effect on you. But remember
the rife comes program with over 2,000 different programs that you could use on different things. So
if your child has strep throat you can run some strep frequencies that could be beneficial to them
but they'd have to be fairly close to the bulb to get those benefits. Same thing with people that
visit your house, same thing with your spouse. When we write programs we don't just put frequencies
for the cancer in the person's program. We'll put frequencies that will help detoxification,
help with the liver, help with the kidneys, help with the gut as well. So it's not uncommon that the
spouse will say boy what's been happening with this rife machine I've been you know having more
bowel movements or feeling better or whatever this condition has improved just because they're improving
their detoxification processes. So that's not uncommon even being in a little bit greater distance
than three feet away but it's all about the frequencies that's being run. That goes into the second
question which was if EMFs are bad for you how is the rife good for you? Well it's all about
the frequencies. So there are certain frequencies that are harmful to us and can negatively affect
cells and those are not frequencies that the rife is using. So when you use an EMF meter and you
measure EMFs those harmful frequencies for you and you put it up to a rife bulb you're not getting
anything negatively coming out of it. You can get negative EMF frequencies from the computer
itself that you're running the rife program with that's why we tell people to close the computer,
put it to sleep. Once you hit run on the program itself it puts the program into the machine itself
so you don't need the computer you could actually turn it off or disconnect it and put it in the
other room if you wanted to but if you put the computer to sleep by closing it effectively the EMF
output on the computer goes down to nearly zero in itself so that's really the best way to do it.
So yeah EMFs can be measured with an electrical EMF device you can measure EMFs and you can buy one
and measure your EMFs that are coming from your modem that's high EMFs typically and those are
the things that you might want to turn off or discontinue use either we have an EMF bag that goes
over your modem that could help lock EMFs so EMFs can be a real danger especially if anybody has
any brain issues and glial cell issues as well. Next question is what are some realistic
expectations that a person can have when starting alternative care? And this gets into I guess my
philosophy of does alternative care cure cancer and my philosophy is no so I do believe that
God can cure cancer and you can be completely wiped out of every cancer cell but that is an
act of God is alternative care a cure of cancer well first of all we can't legally talk about a cure
at all you know because we're not legally treating cancer but in reality I don't think so anyhow
I don't think anybody is ever cured of cancer short of God intervening I even threw the medical
profession and they will say oh you're cured you're completely cancer-free because your PET scan
is completely clean and so you have no cancer cells well honestly that's not even true so a PET
scan is not going to pick up cancer cells it's not going to light up at all unless there you have at
least two to three million cells in a specific mass that it will show positive with PET scan
same thing with a CT scan so just because I have a clean CT scan just because I have a clean PET
scan does not mean I don't have any cancer cells in me and the truth is is that we probably all
have cancer cells in us at any given time and our body is knocking them down our immune system is
killing them off and therefore I may not ever get a diagnosis of cancer because my immune system is
scavenging and I have you know your immune cells is looking for you know pathogens and looking for
cells that look abnormal and they scavenge and destroy those cells and so that's what keeps me from
getting cancer but the truth is I have cancer cells all the time and especially a person
is ever diagnosed with cancer you have circulated tumor cells that are looking for a place to raise
a family somewhere and they're going to different organs and trying to find an opportunity to
start replicating and even when it starts replicating your immune system then could then
scavenge that and kill that so are we ever cured of cancer well I don't even like to talk that
way we want to get people into remission for you know 30 years that would be great so that's really
the goal but what are some realistic expectations when you're starting alternative care
you're trying to slow down the growth and if we can get the the replication cycle because remember
what cancer is cancer is really a cell that is going through rapid replication and that's what
could be dangerous so if we can slow down that replication cycle and get it to start replicating
slower therefore that would be called your cancer's growth is slowing down that's a real good thing
if we can have a person that comes into our clinic and they have let's say masses in their lungs that are
you know four millimeters by nine millimeters and three millimeters by twelve millimeters and three
months later we do another scan and there's still four millimeters by nine millimeters and three
millimeters by twelve millimeters a.k.a. their masses haven't gotten considerably larger they've stayed
the same are we winning the answer is yes so our replication has slowed down possibly even ceased
isn't that then the sea seed of cancer growth yes I know everybody has one step explanation of
I have this mass in my breast or my lungs or wherever it is and I want it to go away therefore I'm
cured of cancer that isn't always reality so sometimes if we can just get it to stop replicating
our body will wall it off and it'll stay there the rest of our life but if we live you know 30 more
years when we're expected to live three to you know six months are we cured of cancer still no but
we're in remission those cells stopped replicating and that's really what the goal is that's what our
goal whether you seek alternative care or whether you seek standards of care or whether you have a
combination of both and that really brings us into the next question too if I choose to do alternative
care do I have to stop be my standards of care if I choose to do alternative care do I have to stop
chemotherapy I know we get a lot of calls where people are like I you know I just found out I have
cancer or I just found out my cancer is growing and my doctor wants me to do XYZ but I have to decide
whether I want to do alternative care or to do what my oncologist wants to do that's that's not the
right way to think you could do alternative care right along with standards of care all the time
yes there's some things I think we spoke about this last week there's some things you don't want to
do if you're going to do chemotherapy you don't want to use strong antioxidants same time you're
using an oxidizing therapy like chemotherapy but the right other nutritional pieces other dietary
pieces can be done right alongside standards of care better fact it will probably greatly increase
your survivability greatly increase the effectiveness of the standards of care and give you a much
better outcome and you're going to be much happier with the results so personally I don't think it should
be called alternative care I think it should be called standard care this is what you should be doing
changing your lifestyle changing your diet because these are the things that got you to the point
where of the diagnosis let's change some of those things up and if we have to use standards of care
aka chemotherapy radiation and surgery then so be it but let's let's get you on a good healthy
protocol to begin with that's going to give you the best outcome possible
next question is it ever too late to start alternative care
no it's never too late to change your diet never too late to start to good getting some good nutrition
in your body it's never really too late to start the rife machine however if a person's body is
completely shut down if a person's body they have no immune system left and you know they're just
a few days to live is it realistic that these things are going to make a giant swing and turn a
person around and yes and no so from a standard thought process you go well yeah it's probably too
late if you're in that state you don't have any immune response left because that's what the rife
really relies on you can't eat or drink you know you're on an IV drip or something like that how
are you going to change your diet yes those things do give us real difficulties and in some cases
you could say it's too late I've had patients where their their family members have asked me that
question and in the past I've said honestly well maybe it is too late and maybe that's showing
was showing a lack of faith on my part and it wasn't to tell I've had numerous patients where in my
rational mind I thought it was too late but the people the family member was wanted to start anyhow
and we saw this unbelievable 180 degree flip of the person's condition that they live for multiple
years after that that just kind of blew my mind and told me that I need to stop putting limitations
on what God could do in a person's life so when we have a person call and maybe the patient can't
even get out of the phone but I'm talking to family members and they're asking is it too late I've
learned to say that that nobody knows about God and that we'd ask that you'd really pray about
your decision in utilizing our services and because it might be too late it might not be too late I don't
have the answer to that question but certainly we get a lot of patients that go I have stage 4
cancer is it too late and I would say to that well that doesn't make any difference it really depends
on the health of your immune system and your ability to be able to recover because most of our patients
are stage 4 when they come to us unfortunately we typically don't have patients that hey I just found
out I have cancer and I wanted to do an alternative approach right away that's a wonderful thing and we
do get some of those but most of our patients are hey I found out I have cancer when three years ago
I did chemo and radiation it worked for a period of time and now the cancer has come back with
the vengeance and my oncologist said that they could do chemotherapy but it's not curative anymore it's
just going to be to help prolong your life and you got a few months to live that's typically our
average patient and we see great results with that meeting the people often live a lot longer years
longer than they were told that they had to live and that's to be a great success so
and then next question we get a lot in this last year is how do you treat it at distance
I don't want to travel I don't want to come to Minnesota we live in Florida how can you take care
of us when we live in California and you're in Minnesota well we've always had our distance plans
because we have always had people that didn't want to travel they they didn't like traveling or they
were not healthy enough to travel so programming a rife can be done without having the person be
here now the benefit of coming to our office is that we can do scanning with a rife machine to get
really tuned in on the frequencies and that is more important the more rare the cancer is so if
you have a cancer that is really no known frequencies for that cancer it's a very rare cancer
it can become more important or cancer that we've never seen before that can become more important but
if you have a cancer that's not as rare breast cancer prostate cancer colon cancer pancreatic cancer
lung cancer you know squamous cell cancer melanomas these are all very common cancers there's a lot of
known frequencies for we can definitely program the rife get you going on that program and utilize
a rife machine we can do distance testing for nutrition we can do distance testing of course all the
genetic testing is simply a saliva sample so we use saliva as our testing sample in a lot of things
distance our distance program we've had distance much success over the last 10 years of our distance
program we've had a much higher use of our distance program in the last year with COVID and we're
having distance good a success with those patients so we never want to discourage anybody from doing
the distance program even if they live across street from the clinic they don't need to come here and
do scanning especially if you have a more common cancer so it's just it's been a great thing so we
can still we can see people from a distance of course we don't get the benefit of you know you know touch
interaction and developing a relationship that's a one-on-one relationship with that person but we do a
lot of our work over a zoom calls anyhow and we do a lot of our work over the phone anyhow so
and then we have a regular zoom calls for our patients every Wednesday afternoon that they can call
in and ask questions at any time at a group zoom call and we record those questions at least
as well and post that up on our blog so look for our blog I also would encourage you if you're watching
this video to utilize our website utilize our blog and utilize a search option on our blog because
there's a lot of information there that you can glean some questions that will in a lot of videos
that will help you answer some of those questions that you might have and then the last question I
want to address today is a question that we get very often and that is will the rife work for
Blake fill in the Blake cancer I mentioned earlier that the doing the distance program if you have a
relatively common cancer is very easy to do and I have a lot of confidence in it but I do
want to caution you to think that because of unfortunately what people have been told commonly
that their cancer is rare I cannot tell you it's at least several times a week that we get a call
saying I have this cancer and my doctor said it's very rare and I need to do chemo right away
and I'm not saying that they should or should not do chemo but many times they list a cancer that is
not very rare so there's a lot of different types of cancer out there and people think that the rife
is going to work better on one type of cancer than it is on another type of cancer and that is
really not true and it we've had patients that have called and they have a type of cancer that
hasn't yet been identified even with multiple multiple biopsies they haven't identified the
primary organ of the cancer because the biopsy is they just can't detect the cells so how do you
program the rife for that so there's ways to test for that there's ways to utilize the rife using
standard cancer programs that can be still extremely beneficial for those patients and we have
multiple patients that are that category that are doing phenomenal that have yet to have their type of
cancer identified and the reason why they didn't go any further because they did it to standards of
care so there could be a lot of success with that so the type of cancer that you have is less important
than digging into those those those four pillars that we dig into when we look at a person's cancer
so is the is the person having triple negative breast cancer at more at risk than a person having
ER positive cancer well from standards of care meaning from your oncologist point of view they say
yes in the reason why triple negative it's a much more aggressive cancer from an oncologist point
of view is really because a whole class of drugs meeting the estrogen blockade drugs are not
available now for that cancer they only have you know they're they're let's say there are a number of
drugs that they could use on breast cancer was this big and now because you have triple negative
breast cancer now the number of drugs that we could use is this big so with a much more dangerous
cancer we're not using drugs from from alternative supportive perspective that we take to help that
person with cancer so that doesn't make it more aggressive or more dangerous from our point of view so
it's we're still using frequencies we're still using nutrition we're still using
nutraceuticals we're still looking at genetics we're looking at causes we're looking at detoxification
we're looking at all these different factors that encompass our four pillars of care it's not so much
the type of cancer that we're concerned with it is the cause of the cancer it's the toxins in the
person's body it's the it's the other factors that we're dealing with to help that person heal
not this limited drug capabilities that standards of care have so I don't ever want a person to think
that that their type of cancer limits them to alternative care or what their standards of care doctor
said and how aggressive their cancer is limits them to not be able to do alternative care even if my
cancer is very aggressive meaning that the the current state of replication is very rapid so it's
growing quickly and I and I need to do chemotherapy too coupling it with alternative
care nutrition nutraceuticals right machine I think it's going to give people a much better outcome
so it's always best to to look at it as holistically as possible take a step back you may choose to do
what your oncologist is asking you to do which may be exactly right for your case but adding the
these other things to it is is going to make your outcome I think much better so at least consider
that all right well thank you very much for another holistic health hour make sure you get your questions
and we'll get those answered on our next week and enjoy your day